ganz schlechte nachricht diese woche der
klimawandel hat award nicht aufgehört
ich hatte gedacht er macht mal pause
schon aus rücksicht auf corona aber
macht ja gar nicht total unhöflich auch
unsere groko dachte klima läuft und dann
dieser paukenschlag aus karlsruhe
teile des klimaschutzgesetzes sind
offiziell verfassungswidrig für alle die
das unterschrieben haben sind quasi
verfassungsfeinde ist ein historisches
urteil kann man so sagen
die politik muss ich jetzt dringend
etwas einfallen lassen und unsere medien
haben scheinbar gewaltfantasien
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat der
politik hier eine ohrfeige erteilt eine
ordentliche partie heftigste und
deftigste uhr folge eine watsche
regelrecht in folge vom höchsten
deutschen gericht eine echte ohrfeige
das ist eine riesen warte und eine
klatsche wer diesen fall gibt eine
ohrfeige touchpen geiler film war die
haut die groko wissen sie noch terence
hill als verfassungsrichter karlsruhe
ist aufgefallen dass gesetz wälzt die
co2 reduktion zu sehr auf die junge
generation ab für die zeit nach 2030
steht fast gar nichts konkretes mehr
drin immer nicht dabei war das doch
gerade die idee wir legen fest
klimaneutralität bis 2050 und jungen
leute überlegen sich wie genau sie das
schaffen wollen
was sollen wir eltern dennoch alles
machen echt peinliches urteil für die
groko was sagen denn jetzt die leute die
das gesetz verbrochen haben zu der voll
blamage
die sich dieses urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ist von
herausragender bedeutung für den
klimaschutz und das großartige an diesem
ich kann das gar nicht sagen anders
seinen coolen spruch des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ist das ist
eigentlich übersetzt folgendes gesagt
hat ziele haben ist ja schön sagen wie
es geht ist noch viel besser warum hast
du es dann nicht gemacht als vizekanzler
hätte ich geradezu cool gefunden
scholz und wieso bitte feiert peter
altmaier das urteil
der mann hat persönlich den ausbau der
windenergie ausgebremst
persönlich ja gut aber vielleicht habe
ich das auch alles falsch verstandene
vielleicht war die groko die ganze zeit
auf seiten von friday future wie konnte
es nur nicht so offen zeigen heimlich
haben die wahrscheinlich mit
demonstriert gegen ihr eigenes
klimaschutzgesetz ja schön wäre es
wirklich absolut rätselhaft eines der
ganz großen rätsel der jüngeren
geschichte wie die auf die demütigung
durch das verfassungsgericht reagieren
als ob man eine vergeigte klassenarbeit
zurückliegt und dann fliegt war du
gelernt habe das war die beschlüsse
deutsche bank die je lesen musste bistum
völlig verblödet - 15 - vielen dank fürs
feedback ich fand's selber total scheiße
ja kein wunder dass so viele lehrer
saufen
seit dem urteil werden jetzt jeden tag
achten sie mal darauf minütlich neue
klimaziele rausgehauen noch mehr co2
noch früher einspart diesmal aber
wirklich
man könnte auch sagen die ziele die wir
verfehlen werden immer großartiger
markus söder kein witz hat allein am
montag drei pressekonferenzen gegeben
hauptsächlich um armin laschet den tag
zu versauen kindergarten laschet fordert
zitat klimaneutralität deutlich vor der
jahrhundertmitte söder kontakt mit 2040
+ ich und wie schafft der söder dass
selbst bei der global ssten aller krisen
am ende immer auf sich und auf bayern
zukommen
unser ziel muss sein dass deutschland in
der eu und ich sagte es für bayern auch
dass bayern mit in deutschland zu einem
role model wird für ökologisches
wirtschaften
aha vielen vielen dank an bewerber
snacks role model wir übrigens in bayern
interessanterweise bei der abstandsregel
für windräder bleibt die die windenergie
ausbremst fakt ist mit den jetzigen
maßnahmen landen wir zum ende des
jahrhunderts
irgendwo zwischen 2 und 3 grad
erderwärmung katastrophe katastrophe
natürlich muss der co2 preis für alle
sektoren hoch und natürlich muss man die
bürger gleichzeitig entlasten
für die akzeptanz der energiewende wer
ist außerdem ganz schön wenn die kosten
siehe strompreis nicht immer
hauptsächlich beim verbraucher landen
die junge freue ich mich aufs
novellierte klimaschutzgesetz also wäre
toll wenn die ganzen neuen vorsätze
verkündet werden und es dann wieder
heißt und ich verstehe auch diejenigen
die sagen ja wer soll ich das denn
glauben dass er das das nächste mal
wirklich schafft und wir glauben da
nicht so richtig daran richtig viel
schöner hätte es nicht zusammenfassen
können
klimaschutz hat bei uns verfassungsrang
und seit dieser woche haben wir es zudem
schriftlich auf kosten kommender
generationen leben ist voller sie und
wenn man mal wissen möchte wie das im
sogenannten boomer lager so ankommt das
gesicht von friedrich merz macht hier
vor nämlich dass klimaschutz ein
grundrecht
ist und damit eine inter generation aale
gerechtigkeit tatsächlich auch
angewendet
und genau das ist der punkt schätzelein
inter generationengerechtigkeit das wort
gibt es überhaupt nicht fritz im märz
sympathisch wie immer die fridays leute
feiern derweil natürlich den erfolg
ihrer klage stoßen wahrscheinlich an mit
fair gehandelter rhabarber schorle oder
was die so machen
andere sind stinksauer und venen im
hintergrund finstere mächte am werk
der chefredakteur der welt herr pocher
zb er schreibt die gut organisierte und
auch mit steuergeld finanzierte grüne
lobby hat einen kleinen erfolg in
karlsruhe eingefahren nein gott
verstehen sie eigentlich was hier läuft
ich nicht deutschland scheinbar eine
demokratie
aber wer zieht hier wirklich die fäden
die banken die autoindustrie die echsen
menschen falsch die mächtigste lobby des
landes sind die kleinen öko branchen von
fridays for future sie kontrollieren
alles inzwischen haben sie sogar
karlsruhe im griff gemobbt und
gedemütigt lädt das höchstgericht in
angst und schrecken vor gewaltbereiten
klima teenies sie diktieren unseren
richtern ihre gesetze
und zwingen sie vegetarisch zu essen
weil sie böse sind
im herbst macht die verstreute friday
sekte dann mit hilfe von massenhypnose
ihre marionette zur kanzlerin
nur drei minuten später muss der letzte
deutsche dieselfahrer aufgeben bleibt
nur eine frage was haben wir diesen
wütenden kindern bloß getan
genau
mächtige junge lobby umgekehrt wird ein
schuh draus
wer hat denn vor allem zurückgesteckt im
corona ja aus solidarität mit den alten
deswegen sagen ja manche die könnten
jetzt beim klima den jungen auch mal was
zurückgeben und auf bestimmte sachen
verzichten
ich frag mal meinen kollegen ulrich von
heesen einen klassischen best age ulrich
wäre das für sie eine option
klar denke ich darüber nach sie werden
lachen ich mal gerade sogar extra eine
kreuzfahrt um da mal intensiv darüber
nachzudenken zu hause kommst ja zunächst
drei wochen all inclusive auf der aida
astra zenica und akku nur für
vollständig geimpft aber um aufs klima
zurückzukommen
sie haben da völlig recht so wie bisher
können wir nicht weitermachen das geht
nicht verstehe
sie fühlen sich also solidarisch mit den
jungen menschen absolut die panther vor
allem aus look down home screen und
später können sie dann meinen
schuldenberg zurückzahlen von der rente
die sie nicht mehr kriegen das stück
generation daher wahrscheinlich auch die
ganze klima wut es ist unsere zukunft
und wir wollen auch wir wollen da auch
leben und das ist eigentlich gut ist das
wir fordern müssen dass wir weiter leben
können von den erwachsen wird keinen
schritt in richtung konkretes handeln
getan das ist dermaßen falsch und
verlogen
das ist für uns entsetzlich es ist
unsere zukunft und nicht die
erwachsene menschen die als auch schon
irgendwann sterben als alles was wir tun
woher will der kleine klugscheißer dem
wissen wann ich den arsch zu kneifen
ich bin privat versichert das kann sich
ewig ziehen er ist jung hat also einmal
die luft aus meinem glas servicewüste
mittelmeer aber karlsruhe hat doch recht
der von heesen wir versauen der nächsten
generation die zukunft verballern ohne
ende co2 und die dürfen dann später
nicht mehr
sorry aber da gibt es ja eine ganz
einfache regeln
wir waren zuerst da punkt das ist wie
hier am buffet wenn ich da zu spät komme
kann ich auch nicht rumheulen
geschrieben sind alle oder das co2 ja
dann kommen halt früher fast die können
nichts dafür dass sie später geboren
sind ausreden haben wir alle welt gehen
ich bin ja prinzipiell total für
klimaschutz aber mit langfristigen
zielen ab jetzt zum beispiel beschlossen
ab 2050 verzichte ich komplett auf
flugreisen mit 108 und macht nur noch
fahrradtour schön aber das ist ja genau
das problem
es gibt tatsächlich kein einziges land
auf dem planeten dass sich ausreichend
kurzfristige reduktionsziele setzt ja
warum auch
wer weiß was sie plagen später rates
erfinden
die sind doch so schlau klar bis zu drei
grad erderwärmung klingt bedrohlich
andererseits gerade hier auf dem
oberdeck denke ich abends oft jetzt so
drei grad mehr wer perfekt aber das darf
man ja heute alles nicht mehr sagen aha
also ihm geht super ja ja nein gleich
fängt hier das showprogramm an habe ich
früher immer gern geguckt bisschen sexy
tanz und so aber wenn du nur zweimal
geimpfte tänzer an bord lässt kriegst du
halt auch nur bestimmte jahrgänge hallo
hallo ich glaube ich gehe heute früh ins
bett
ulrich von heesen vielen dank
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und 70 -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist - hersteller
[Musik]